(intense music)
- Text me if you need anything.
- Alright, bye loser.
- Just tryin' to be a good older brother.
- You must be Kelsey.
Thanks so much for babysitting
at the last minute.
- No problem.
- Just make yourself at
home, if you need anything
just Facebook message
me, or email works too,
or you can Twitter DM me, or Instagram DM,
or add me on Snapchat and send me a snap.
(phone ringing)
(intense dark music)
- What the hell?
What's voicemail?
New phone, who dis?
(phone ringing)
Ben, have you been calling me?
- Like from a phone, God no.
- [Kelsey] Should I tweet the police?
- Maybe it's just a customer
satisfaction survey.
- [Kelsey] They left a voicemail.
- Oh my God.
Stay calm, you're safe inside that house.
(phone ringing)
- Stop calling me you sick...
- [Voiceover] Kelsey, it's the police.
We've received multiple reports
of phone calls in that location.
It's all coming from the same number.
(intense music)
- [Kelsey] The internet's down.
I can't send Snapchats.
(screams)
(intense exciting music)
- [Voiceover] Kelsey, is that you?
It's your nana.
- Nana!
You need to learn how to (beep) text!
(intense music)